hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called Polina
spoilers ahead watch out and stay safe
the movie begins in a film studio where
a woman named Paulina and her co-actor
are shooting a scene for a movie
afterwards her daughter Nina appears
wearing a movie costume then the two go
for a walk where Paulina says that there
are different movie studios and each one
has a different world inside of it it's
revealed that the movie sets and Studios
were built by polina's parents which now
belong to Polina and will one day be
passed down to Nina Polina shows Nina
Studio One and says that this is where
her life completely changed she then
begins to narrate her story from when
she was a kid and the events which
happened just a day before her 12th
birthday the scene cuts into the past
where an 11 year old Paulina is seen
living with her aunt vivara and cousin
Dylan it turns out that vervara didn't
treat Polina well and used to keep her
locked up in her small room despite
having a huge mansion it's also revealed
that at the time Paulina didn't have any
recollection of her parents faces and in
addition vivara didn't answer any of her
questions about them one day Dylan
enters her room and gives her a
mysterious box before leaving curious to
see what is inside she opens the box and
finds Film Studio documents and a torn
picture of a man Paulina immediately
suspects the man in the photo to be her
father but isn't sure all of a sudden
Aunt vivara arrives there and
interrogates her on where she found the
box however Paulina lies and says that
she found the box while snooping around
in Dylan's room she then asks rivara if
the man in the photo is her father to
which she claims that her parents are
dead after a while vervara calls Dylan
in the room where he throws the box in
the fireplace the two then exit the room
and lock Polina inside fortunately she
manages to retrieve the torn photo and
some additional Film Studio documents
before they burn the scene then cuts to
a man who is set free from jail it's
revealed that the man is called Anton
who is actually pulling his father
however Anton is reminded by a judge
that he is on parole for the rest of his
life and is also not able to see or
visit his daughter meanwhile Paulina
eavesdrops and Dylan's conversation
where she learns that they are going to
poison her they don't want Polina to
learn the truth about her parents as she
gets older so determined to escape she
successfully unlocks herself and manages
to Escape the Mansion meanwhile and
vervara and Dylan poisoned paulina's K
can take it to her room where they find
out that she has escaped they then
figure out she has gone to the movie
studios so Rivera orders Dylan to fetch
Polina either dead or alive the scene
cuts to Polina arriving at the film
studio where she sees many other kids
she finds out that the kids are there
for a film workshop and decides to blend
in with them to be able to enter the
studio pravara then Rings the movie
studio manager Saul and orders him to
search for Polina wasting no time Saul
rushes and informs the security guards
of the matter a while later as Paulina
enjoys a play from the other children
Saul finds and chases after her Polina
manages to lose him but is again chased
by Dylan who has arrived she hardly
enter Studio One and loses Dylan off her
tail inside she Witnesses a holographic
man calling her who surprisingly knows
her name the man begins to explain that
he is from one side of a silver screen
and Paulina as from the other side he
then tells her that if she finds all the
missing pieces of the photo then the
complete picture we'll tell Paulina the
truth about her parents he also reveals
that she has until midnight to complete
the task and failure in doing so will
result in Paulina getting stuck on the
other side of the Silver Screen forever
so eager to learn the truth Polina
decides to go and find the lost pieces
of the photo she hurriedly opens one of
the studio doors which reveals a
completely different world on entering
it looks like a war zone as Rubble fire
and broken Vehicles surround her she
soon approaches a broken down tank and
knocks to see if anyone is inside to her
surprise she finds a boy named Sasha who
orders her to go away Polina however
doesn't listen to him and soon a tank
slowly rolls up towards them pelina
quickly scurries to a nearby hiding spot
where as Sasha gets out of his vehicle
and surrenders before being apprehended
by the soldiers after they leave Polina
heads inside Sasha's vehicle and and
luckily finds the second part of the
photo she is shocked to see a little
girl's picture on it and recognizes it
as herself so she heads to where the
soldiers are keeping Sasha captive and
while they are distracted she asks him
where he got the photo he informs
Paulina that he was given the photo by
Cleopatra Helena wants more information
so she frees Sasha and decides to go
with him to find Cleopatra however as
they run the two get separated and
Paulina finds herself outside the studio
back in her normal World unfortunately
she is not able to catch her breath as
Dylan finds her and chases her once
again with nowhere to run to she rushes
inside Studio three barely escaping from
Dylan inside the studio she finds
herself in a music school where Saul is
now in the form of the principle he then
escorts her to a music class thinking
that she is a new student the music
teacher however seems to be very grumpy
and cruel to the students as she even
has a section of the classmate to look
like a jail cell for punishing them the
teacher then orders a boy named Cleo to
play the piano and he plays it
beautifully shortly after Saul hears the
beautiful Melody that Cleo is playing
and enters the class he blames the class
teacher that she has only been mean and
cruel and hasn't found out the true
potential of her students so he locks
the teacher inside the jail cell while
the other children go out for recess
except Polina and Cleo in the next scene
Paulina confronts Cleo and asks him if
he is Cleopatra hearing this he finally
reveals himself in his true Egyptian
clothing and confirms his identity
Polina then shows the photo to him and
finds out that he had traded the other
part of the photo for his clothing with
a person called boom boom Polina still
needs the last piece of the photo and
asks Cleopatra to help her despite him
being scared of boom boom Polina manages
to convince him to help meanwhile Anton
visits for vara's mansion and demands to
see his daughter fervara informs him
that she has escaped but doesn't tell
him where she has gone however Anton
manages to find out where she is after
he punches and asks the family driver
Edward meanwhile Polina and Cleopatra
walk into Studio 4 where they reach a
gymnasium and made a girl when Paulina
asks her about the pictures she informs
them that she gave the pictures to the
big guy in the gym the little girl then
confronts the huge bulky guy and asks
for the photo to which he proposes that
she should fight for it so she and the
big guy enter the ring where the little
girl dominates the fight she is quick
and small enabling her to dodge punches
and land a significant amount of shots
but suddenly the big guy lands a huge
punch on her sending her flying at which
point Cleopatra and Polina decide to
help the big guy still overpowers the
two but in the nick of time Sasha
materializes through the wall and comes
to the rescue he then jumps on top of
the big guy covering his face and eyes
after this the three use the ropes of
the Ring to tie the big guy's feet while
the girl lands the final blow knocking
him out once he awakens Paulina asks for
the picture however after getting the
picture of her mother she realizes that
one piece is still missing to complete
the photo all of a sudden the big guy
starts crying and Paulina thinks that he
knows something about the last piece so
they enter a hospital behind another
Studio door where they encounter Edward
who is a mad scientist he orders a nurse
to take Cleopatra to experiment on him
while the others watch over the big guy
it has been a while but the big guy
continues to cry as he is a mute he
writes on a piece of paper that he
misses his girlfriend who is revealed to
be a King's Daughter hearing this the
children promised to find his girlfriend
but only if he helps them rescue
Cleopatra meanwhile Edwards plan to
electrocute Cleo backfires and he ends
up electrocuting himself shortly after
the kids reached the room where
Cleopatra is held and successfully
rescue him afterwards they find a girl
inside a room who seems to be friends
with the big guy it's then revealed that
the two are from the Viking studio and
that they were sent by the princess to
find a potion for the king who is
poisoned by the new evil King's wife so
to escape the hospital the big guy
dresses up as a doctor and places the
kids in a cart he then manages to get
through all the guards in the meantime
vervara tells Saul that he must find
Anton and Paulina as soon as possible
because if the two come to know the
truth both Saul and she will end up in
prison elsewhere Polina runs out of the
studio with her friends but they
disappear instantly all of a sudden
Dylan starts chasing her prompting her
to hide in a closet inside a warehouse
Dylan then searches for Paulina and
eventually finds her but he is stopped
by Anton who arrives just in time he
buys Paulina some time before getting
knocked by Dylan she escapes from the
warehouse and enters Studio 6 where she
finds a chemistry lab and all her
friends it turns out that the little
girl has turned into a teapot after
drinking a weird potion soon after they
find a scientist and ask him to cure
their friend the latter experiments a
little bit and accidentally turns turns
Sasha into a frog afterwards Cleo tries
to make his own cure which surprisingly
works for both Sasha and the little girl
making them human again Helena then
wants to see if the potion can restore
the missing piece of the photo
surprisingly the plan works the photo
comes out and reveals a woman holding a
newborn baby this confuses Polina and
when she exits the studio she again
finds Dylan waiting for her hence she
she begins to run through a forest while
Anton wakes up and runs after Dylan in
the next scene Paulina stumbles across
Studio 7 and enters through a door that
disappears after she closes it this
makes Dylan confused and all of a sudden
Anton hits him from behind he wins the
fight while Polina finds herself in the
Viking Studio moments later it's
revealed that the guards have caught the
big guy and so they restrain him on a
Podium meanwhile the new king and queen
mock the princess who looks at the big
guy the queen then demands a child for
her dinner so the guards pick Cleopatra
and bring him to the queen meanwhile
Paulina finds Sasha in a cage who
advises her to free the big guy and help
the princess so Paulina frees the big
man who rescues the princess from the
guards it turns out the king is in
serious condition and is in a shed
Paulina gives him the potion and
surprisingly the king becomes well in an
instant the princess then tells her
father that he was poisoned by the queen
moments later the queen comes to the
house and pretends to be happy to see
him alive however the king doesn't pay
any attention to her and has to regain
the throne this however doesn't sit
right with the evil King so he blows a
magic horn which unleashes a monster
called dragger in order to fend off
dragger the big man drinks a potion to
get stronger and begins to fight him
one-on-one at first the big man lands
many blows on dragonf but the evil King
Keeps On Healing The Monster by
continuously sounding the horn so the
little girl approaches the evil King and
punches him in the face which causes him
to drop the magic horn this enables the
big guy to easily defeat dragger as he
is not able to heal anymore suddenly
after the big guy's Victory the evil
King stabs him from behind and runs away
with time running out the kids
immediately spring into action and save
the big guy using the potion this elates
the princess so she decides to give
Polina a hand Cleopatra a surprise the
two board a boat at night where they
finally meet paulina's mother she
reveals that Cleo is actually paulina's
brother and that he died with her during
a fire long ago it turns out that eight
years ago a fire destroyed the film
studio which took her mother and Cleo's
life and for that Anton was wrongly
blamed so the mother requests Paulina to
return to the real world to stop Aunt
vervara's plan to sell the studio
afterwards Polina and Cleo exit the
Viking Studio from a movie screen and
meet a group of friends she is then
reunited with her father but shortly
after vervara arrives inside the studio
with the police the police attempt to
arrest Anton but all of a sudden the
Hologram appears out of thin air and
plays a video on the movie screen the
video shows Rivera asking paulina's
mother to sell the movie studio as it
was not generating enough money
paulina's mother however disagrees as
her parents worked very hard to build it
it is then revealed that it was actually
vivara who was responsible for the fire
in the film studio which takes the life
of paulina's mother and Cleo the video
also shows Anton saving Polina from the
fire before getting blamed for
everything seeing this the police start
chasing varvara Dylan and her other
accomplices throughout the studio they
soon reach an empty warehouse and
strangely begin eating The Poisoned cake
which was originally meant for Paulina
meanwhile Polina Anton her other friends
celebrate her 12th birthday the scene
cuts into the present where paulina's
daughter Nina makes her way into Studio
One to start her own adventure just like
young Paulina did thanks for watching
subscribe and hit that like button to
help our Channel grow turn on the
notifications so you won't miss any of
our new videos